this tannery is infamous as the
foul-smelling place in all of Fez
Morocco tanning hides may be dirty and
smelly work but somebody has to do it
every day
17-year old mo seen must wind his way
through the ancient alleyways of Fez he
is following in the footsteps of a
countless generations who have labored
before him in this 600 year old tannery
my first time here the smell was
terrible I felt like I was suffocating I
couldn't bear but it's been a while the
smell simply became normal it's at the
end I no longer noticed it at all after
just three years here Messines tenure
has been relatively brief but his father
Abdel has been reading in the tannery
stench for more than three decades each
delivery of skins fresh from the
slaughter means the start of a stinking
wet filthy process of all the foul tasks
no scene must do few are worse than
washing the animal skins and there's no
other way to do it than to climb right
into the tub a fetid sewer of animal
hides flesh hair and bacteria exposure
to the filth makes mo seen and his
co-workers more susceptible to
infections particularly if they were to
have any open sores or cuts while no
scene rinses his lamb skins others
prepare cow hides for tanning scraping
their leftovers into the Seine near
stagnant pool nothing about this job's
for the faint of heart
but mo scene has learned to appreciate
its benefits
my friends who work in other professions
tell me that my job is good because I
can take a swim in the water to the some
it's not like other jobs such as working
for shoemakers where you have to stay in
the same place all day long
the reward for carrying out this
unappealing job brings beginning
Tanner's just two dollars a day and very
experienced ones about five dollars much
of the tanneries odor comes from its
potent and pungent secret ingredient
pigeon droppings most scene gathers the
droppings from the rooftops of Fez then
he's ready for the dirtiest and the
smelliest job of all wading into a vat
of excrement the stench is overpowering
but most seen must keep his head and be
sure to add just the right amount of
water to the pigeon droppings the
perfect mix will help make the skin
supple but not too soft
pigeon droppings have a burning quality
so when you put it on the skin it bites
into it and softens it and then the skin
becomes like a piece of cloth but to
transform these raw hides into leather
cloth requires most seen to get down and
dirty shoeless he can use his toes and
heels to knead the skins over and over
for almost three hours he Trump's around
the VAT even apart from the smell it's a
difficult chore requiring strength and
endurance
finally the skins are soft enough to
please the expert his father AB doubt
this is a very good job just look at
what we produce it's beautiful
my son made this it's a product to be
proud of and few who end up wearing this
leather on their feet will ever know
that it was crafted in one of the
foul-smelling places on earth